so you tell me Matt did a review of the
little professor yeah was he all ironic
about it that says if he's steering at
you through a frosted bathroom window I
think that would be fair to say there
was sarcasm controversial II as opposed
to me asking the calculator a question
and giving me the answer we're doing
this the other way around how dare he
how dare he because the little professor
was a major influence on my young
mathematical career because I had a
little professor when I was a kid and
this is it that's the same one this is
the one I hurt yet this is my little
professor so did the one that Matt
showed you was it different very
headlock an LCD screen that is a
pretender whatever Matt showed you that
is not the little professor this is the
little professor so this is the real
thing this is mine has seen life I've
lost the back of it through childhood
rubbish Ness so I had this mad I know it
was a birthday or Christmas or something
when I was eight something like that
this gives me warm nostalgic feelings
this I my love my this little professor
guy there he is look at him with his
glasses and his mustache in his
mortarboard I've looked up what the
history of the little professor was and
it was they were first devised in 1976
it was the world's first electronic
educational toy so that's a claim to
fame this is the second generation this
comes from the 1980s but not an LCD
screen an LED screen yeah this is how we
did things in the early 1980s so we on
level one and we're going to plus
problems so the little professor would
set you arithmetic problems you get ten
arithmetic problems they'd be either
plus problems subtraction problems
division multiplication problems there's
four levels level one two three and four
going from easy to hard
and I think when I was eight I could do
the hard multiplication problems shall
we see if I can still do the hard work
you think you want to put your
reputation on the line I am putting my
reputation on the line so give you
multiplication problems I'm going to
level four I'll put some warnings and
advance it sometimes the buttons are
sticky sometimes they're all they're a
bit sometimes they don't accept what I
press and that it this happens all right
all right
go oh I've got 24 man that's hard 24 by
26 so what is 24 by 26 let's see so
fifty to five hundred and twenty-five
hundred twenty plus four lots of 26 so
I'm up to six hundred six hundred and
twenty-four
yes that was though saying I was a tough
one that was that was a tough tough
first one yeah this is that they go 24
by six
okay 4 by 6 let's do five times so come
on
that's C and I reckon it is 144 one four
four all right
this meant something to me this is
important it means something to me now
so this encouraged my mathematical
interests perhaps well what it does is
if you're a kid who gets arithmetic
early on then it's very easy to be
validated to be encouraged because when
you're given lists of arithmetic
problems it's very easy to get ticks
which makes you feel good and it
encourages you and you get all I'm good
at maths people say well done you're
very good at maths oh I must be good at
maths and you do feel encouraged and you
do take it on further now
I would argue that arithmetic is not
maths now that I'm an older
mathematician I wish my take is part of
maths it's a small part of math but it's
not math it's not what I do it's not
what I do for a living I don't do
arithmetic for a living but you can get
definitely things like this would
encourage a young mathematician someone
who's got some ability that way this is
encouraging to take it further I've kept
this as you can tell it survived other
toys being thrown out when I was a
teenager at university I did math so I
thought oh well that's like that's like
she quite fun to keep around now cuz
that's checked that the universe now I
didn't take it to university when but I
thought if I become like a doctor of
Matt's
now I did not say to anyone that I had
any ambition to be a doctor of math that
was a thought in the back of my head I
thought maybe if I do well at university
maybe I could be like a doctor of math
that'd be cool doc didn't I didn't know
I was going to pass my exams before
maybe wouldn't it be nice if it when I'm
a super important professor to still
have this and I can keep this in a glass
case in my office because we look alike
so it would be nice to keep around and
that's what I did so I went to my
parents house I did I grabbed it there
it's now living in my house and one day
it's going to take pride of price number
for Museum and I thought do you know how
to count stop do you know you can see
they have these in museums now if you go
to the Science Museum in London they
have one of these in a glass case how do
I feel lastly you know in our videos
about calculators we traditionally like
do a test like a durability test like
destroy them or set fire to them and I'm
guessing we're not doing that get out
get don't even think about out